[Musique]
notre business
d'utiliser une demande pour avoir une
excuse de faire déclencher une action
assurance médicament taxe sur les
profits excessifs un système de santé
pleinement public le NPD des objectifs
ambitieux qu'ils souhaitent imposer au
gouvernement de Justin Trudeau mais il
prête à mettre en péril l'entente qui
garantit la survie du gouvernement si
ces demandes sont ignorées je me tourne
vers Peter giulian le leader d'une [__]
en chambre qui est avec nous et ce joli
merci d'être là ça m'a fait plaisir
quels sont les chances qu'on se retrouve
en campagne électorale en 2023 d'après
vous mais là je pense stock médecine et
MPD était très clair on continue à
travailler pour les gens pour aider les
gens les soins dentaires
un exemple et c'est fait à travers la
lorgnette d'une entente vous appuyez le
gouvernement Trudeau si vous êtes
satisfait du travail oui et cette année
ça va être une année importante parce
que là on a le programme de soins
dentaires qui devait débuter mais aussi
il y a des questions d'assurance
médicament ça quelque chose extrêmement
important c'est important à travers les
pays parce que des gens qui payent trop
cher pour le médicament et même des gens
qui meurent chaque année parce qu'ils
ont passé d'argent pour payer leurs
médicaments ça c'est le point de rupture
donc si par exemple à la fin 2023 il y a
pas d'assurance médicament il y a pas de
programme il y a pas où est-ce que vous
tracez la ligne à quel moment vous êtes
ok c'est fini dans l'entente c'est très
clair que le projet de loi de présenter
et adopter au Parlement canadien par la
suite ça prend des négociations avec les
Québec et les provinces et ensuite c'est
de mettre en place ce programme il y a
des états voilà il y a un budget qui
s'en vient ça normalement le
gouvernement libéral peut compter sur
l'appui du NPD est-ce qu'il y aurait des
éléments est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui
pourraient ne pas se retrouver dans le
budget ou qui pourrait il y a une raison
qui pourrait faire en sorte que vous
n'êtes pas capable d'appuyer ce budget
on a toujours dit que la crise du
logement surtout la crise du logement
qui touchent des communautés éloignées
des communautés ça c'est quelque chose
qui doit être réglé c'est quand on pense
aujourd'hui le nombre des familles qui
en relâchent pour garder un toit sur le
tête c'est important que le gouvernement
fait ses investissements là mais pas
pour nous l'importance on veut avancer
la cause des gens des gens ont subi
énormément des conséquences de la
pandémie il y en arach vraiment au
niveau économique et il faut maintenant
quand même des ressources pour aider ces
familles là et les gens à travers le
pays le taxe monsieur sing en parlait la
semaine dernière la taxe sur les profits
excessifs si c'est pas dans le budget
vous votez quand même pour le budget
mais nous on pousse toujours pour avoir
une système d'impôts qui est saine là on
voit avec les périodes fiscaux que les
gens
quittent effectivement les prendre la
jante et ils s'en vont du pays il faut
quand même en place une système d'impôts
équitable maintenant les conservateurs
et les libéraux ne sont pas d'accord
là-dessus on va continuer à pousser il y
a pas vous ce n'est pas comme quelqu'un
qui est disposé à renverser le
gouvernement ou un maître fait à
l'entente cette année ça prendrait il y
a pas de raison à court terme ou en tout
cas de votre point de vue il y a pas de
raison pour mettre un terme à l'entente
si le gouvernement tient pas par perdre
c'est là que les autres ils mettent
final
qui va mettre fin à l'entendre pour nous
il faut que le gouvernement tienne
parole et nous on va continuer à
travailler justement pour qu'on mette en
place toutes ces mesures là pour aider
les gens vous en avez parlé un peu
durant la rencontre je présume avec vos
collègues du caucus avez-vous
l'impression que c'est difficile pour le
NPD de tirer profit de cette entente là
avez-vous la visibilité que vous pensiez
avoir avec ça le contraire dans mon
contenu
là les gens sont très au courant que les
différences qui voient l'aide qui voit
au niveau de soins dentaires au niveau
de l'aide au logement pour eux ils
donnent le train de crédit au MPD je
pense la même chose à travers le pays
les gens comprennent que le gouvernement
commence à agir grâce effectivement des
joggs médecins à l'exemple
vous avez parlé beaucoup de santé cette
semaine et j'ai eu l'impression que la
déclaration ou le projet de dogford en
Ontario de confié à des cliniques
privées le soin certaines chirurgies
pour tenter de désengorger le système ça
vous inquiète ça vous inquiète parce que
vous avez l'impression que c'est une
privatisation par derrière qu'est-ce que
Ottawa devrait faire pour ça mais
effectivement on en a déjà le Loi
canadienne sur le santé on a déjà des
mesures qui devraient être faites c'est
au gouvernement
il y a personne vous vous entrez dans
une clinique privée avec une carte
d'assurance maladie et c'est le
gouvernement qui paie pour la procédure
on sait très bien que une fois qu'on
mette le profit et le privé dans le
système de santé en a vu ça c'est ce que
tu vois le gouvernement commence aussi
de mettre une partie privée dans un
système de santé les lignes d'ATT c'est
trop large parce que quand la mettre la
jante privée et il faut satisfaire les
profit plutôt que des investir dans un
système public on a un système public
qui se dégrade puis un moins bon qualité
il y a un système public qui fonctionne
pas il y a un système public qui est
paralysé dans lequel il y a des grosses
périodes d'attentes on a de la
difficulté à mettre la main sur des
médecins de famille on fait quoi mais là
c'est pas notre gouvernement qui démonte
le livre shop plein [__] était à l'origine
même de notre système de santé si Tommy
dogglès bien sûr qui est provoqué de
mise en place d'un système de santé il
faut investir il faut bien sûr de faire
une sorte que on est plus d'être accepté
des médecins qui sont entraînés à
l'extérieur formé à l'extérieur du pays
qui sont ici au Canada mais qui a aucune
processus pourrait être accepté comme
des médecines ici au Canada c'est des
choses que le gouvernement fait réel
peut prendre ça prend de leadership et
c'est ça malheureusement qui manque que
fait ça elle se fait taper sur les
doigts pendant les provinces en disant
c'est de compétences provinciales ces
choses la livraison des soins de la
certification des médecins c'est pas
Ottawa qui s'en occupe comment on fait
pour contourner ça c'est le gouvernement
fédéral qui doit travailler avec les
Québec et les provinces ça c'est
important mais là le gouvernement feral
a poésie depuis des années on a vu le
même chose sur les conservateurs il faut
maintenant agir pour renforcer notre
système public et il y a des solutions
qui sont là mais ça prend un leadership
que qui a un autre avis manque au
gouvernement actuel et au gouvernement
précédent j'avais dit en début
d'entrevue pas d'élection quand il
semble pas y avoir d'élections à court
terme 2023 quand est-ce qu'on part en
campagne mais là pour nous on va
continuer à lutter pour les gens on va
continuer à travailler fort pour les
gens et quand tu es aussi longtemps que
le gouvernement tienne parole et mettent
en place toutes les choses qu'on a
discuté longtemps on va continuer mais
il faut que le gouvernement tienne
parole merci beaucoup ça me fait plaisir